ali fassi commence
mais me regarde tous et ça me laisse
sans voix
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes on entend
très bien et vous vous m'entendez ben tu
vois un vide et emploi ça va bien se
passer
regardez son coût y sont bienveillants
mais qu'est-ce que tu en fais tu mets
pas ma plate ou pas tranquille on arrête
de me surveiller
tu te trompes
mais non je ne te surveille pas je
veille sur toi bon mais c'est comme tu
voudras si tu peux faire être en colère
et crier c'est toi qui vois mais fais
attention à moi où tu risquerais de me
perdre à cause de toi parfois je deviens
toute blanche ou rocailleuse quand je ne
disparaît pas totalement
tu devrais savoir que je referais
exactement tout ce que tu es et ce que
tu ressens à chaque instant tu veux plus
rien de caché je suis ta meilleure amie
allez on va prendre toi il dit vers tout
ce que j'étais à tri
et oui ma voix me parle et elle a
toujours raison comment je le sais mais
bien une connaissance depuis très
longtemps toutes ses deux plus d'un
demi-siècle d'amitié ça compte
et aussi parce que comme en berne a dit
je suis orthophonie depuis 30 ans
gd beaucoup de personnes à réparer leurs
voix des modules d aphonie et même des
paralysies c'est ce qui nous a permis de
comprendre les liens entre la voie la
personnalité et la santé
car ce qui est vraiment passionnant avec
la voix ce que j'aime en tout cas c'est
qu'on travaille avec plusieurs facteurs
qui sont la posture la respiration
l'articulation le rythme la hauteur le
timbre et l'intensité c'est pour ça que
on parle aussi de signature vocale
prenons par exemple les modules nodus ce
sont des petites moules qui se forment
dans les personnes parlent trop fort
sont comme les pendus aux cordes vocales
ce que les corps sont au pied et sa part
est ce parce que les gens tapent sur
leurs ports vocale en forçant sur les
sons sens même crié alors les premiers
conseils cantonaux patience et de parler
moins fort d'être doux avec leurs voix
et surtout d'arrêter de crier
eric est souvent s'ils dépassent les
patients mais tous ces conseils en
pratique et nous dit disparaît souvent
aussi vite qu'ils sont arrivés mais
arrêtez de crier ce n'est pas que pour
faire disparaître les modules ça c'est
la partie émergée de l'iceberg en
profondeur il se passe des choses encore
plus intéressantes mais patients
reviennent aussi en me disant qu'ils se
sentent plus calme le fait de ses pieds
de forcer sur les sons leur permet de
moins forcer les choses en général lieu
de s'égosiller à travers les murs réels
ou imaginaires ils se rapprochent de
leurs enfants de leur conjoint leurs
collègues et ça facilite les échanges il
se rend compte que quand ils prennent
soin de leur voix ils communiquent mieux
avec les autres ils prennent aussi
confiance en eux et ils ont plus de
succès professionnel c'est incroyable
mais arrêtez de crier donc on m'a dit
c'est pas seulement pour faire disparaît
les modules et la voix s'est pas
seulement pour communiquer et aussi pour
mieux son temps il faut mieux s'écouter
et pour s'écouter il faut savoir ce
terme savez tout oui parce que pour
poser la voix il faut se taire pour
faire des pauses respiratoires efficace
sans effort c'est à dire pratiquer une
respiration calme et profonde
est ce que ça vous rappelle quelque
chose la respiration calme et profonde
oui non quelques-uns et bien justement
c'est la respiration qui est préconisée
depuis des millénaires pour atteindre
les états de relaxation avancées de nos
jours tous les bons médecins
mais bon la recommande pour gérer les
troubles anxieux le stress est en
général pour les troubles émotionnels
qui entraîne des maladies
psychosomatiques
on commençait aussi à la recommander
pour la prévention des maladies
neurodégénératives comme l'alzheimer et
même pour prévenir le vieillissement
alors tout ça j'ai eu la grande chance
de la prendre assez tôt parce que non
seulement les orthophonistes depuis
l'âge de 22 ans
mais en plus je chantais tout ce que ma
voix m'a appris sur moi je les ai
d'abord utilisé sur moi pour apprendre à
gérer mon corps mais mon propre stress
comme aujourd'hui mais propose émotions
et aujourd'hui est bien plus miézan une
répétition les mots du dos les insomnies
et la liste est longue
je suis en meilleure santé à 52 ans
aujourd'hui 45
alors si votre voix vous parle vous
aussi écoutez la elle vous apprendra à
gérer votre santé vous apprendrez à
écouter les signes de votre corps avoir
une meilleure hygiène de vie meilleure
respiration
vous apprendrez à mieux gérer vos
émotions à mieux communiquer c'est ce
que j'appelle la voie du succès
- du succès ça me plaît ça et tu
pourrais faire dire aussi que c'est
grâce à marcory et que le ville de beer
des médicaments et oui c'est vrai la
libye est là encore est dans cette voie
et surtout d'en créer
souvent et avec tout cela votre voix
vous sera toujours très fidèle et vous
pourrez discuter plus longtemps de vive
voix avec la vie merci
[Applaudissements]